hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
july 19th 2021
what's going on how
how the hell's it going with you you're
doing good i hope so
i'm rooting for you i'm not one of these
people you know you start getting
something good going on and then i get
all upset
you know why that is is it because i'm a
good person
is it because i have a good heart no
it's because i'm having a good week
that's how it works if you're a human
being if you're have
you got [ __ ] you can be happy when other
people have
[ __ ] you don't got [ __ ]
that's when you start going with this
[ __ ] guy he didn't work for [ __ ] his
[ __ ] parents
bought him that [ __ ] car dude if i
was in his family dude i'd be [ __ ]
bieber
google kid
that's how it is that's how it is as a
human being
you know you know i saw a mercedes-benz
with
ben's uh and the front license plate
said uh something like don't be hating
you know and it's just like you know
you're really [ __ ] up you have a
mercedes you don't need to stoop to that
level
all right now we know that you bought
the car
for the simple reason of [ __ ] driving
around
showing it off
so all that all that [ __ ] license
plate says to me is you're actually not
really
happy you know because you went out you
bought something
you know sure it makes you happy as
you're buying it you start tingling you
know
you start driving by all the bad [ __ ]
as the kids say
right and all of a sudden they're
[ __ ] turning around
huh why do they like you they like you
because they got that car
because you got the car that's why and
just like you
they don't like you either for you
i'm such a [ __ ] why am i such a [ __ ]
um i just thought you know you got a
mercedes-benz it's german engineering i
mean it's a [ __ ] sports car with four
doors
you don't need to be [ __ ] rubbing
people's face in it
you really don't but you know people do
it
anyway i don't understand why can't
people be perfect like me
um that's that's the theme of this
podcast why do i
have everything all figured out oh
because i don't like to be challenged so
i surround myself with weak people
kidding
um all right please announce new show
added all right september 10th
10 fran tarkinton
oh jesus there's another number 10 that
just oh god he [ __ ] had the [ __ ]
patriots number
huh eli manning number 10.
number 10 two more super bowls in fran
tarkinton who would have had one
you know if the [ __ ] vikings were
eating their wheaties the way the
steelers were
wink wink um september 10th
at the bryce jordan center
university park pennsylvania i'm gonna
hang around and go to that [ __ ] penn
state game afterward
very excited for that uh or maybe it's
uh the thursday before because i think
i'm in atlantic city the day after i
don't i don't know how it works
or maybe it's that weekend i don't
[ __ ] know all right pre-sale is
thursday
uh july 22nd at 10 a.m eastern
to thursday july 22nd at 10 pm eastern
so it's basically 12 hours
the code is monday all capitals
m-o-n-d-a
v pilots out there mike oscar november
delta
alpha yankee on sale friday uh
to everybody the general public 7
23 at 10 a.m eastern standard time once
again thursday 7 22 10 a.m eastern
standard time
is the pre-sale to that night at 10 p.m
east coast time all right so all you
[ __ ] cokeheads should still be up
out here west be able to get the front
row tickets i can watch your [ __ ]
sweat and
grinding your goddamn teeth uh speaking
of [ __ ] cokeheads oh my god
is there anything better being stone
sober and having some [ __ ] guy just
[ __ ]
gak gacked out of his [ __ ] mind
coming up to you
sweaty
[ __ ] drug sweat i'll be honest with
you i'm an old man okay
bill we knew this all right but i just
got to say this i don't know what he was
on
okay there's like a real cool thing
right now where i think after all these
years of drug abuse
that the young people one of the few
advantages young people have right now
which youth is not an advantage right
now the way this [ __ ] climate is
going
these poor kids they're down to two
seasons all right
they get some they get [ __ ] summer
and winter that's it
all right at least the one thing the
previous generations all of us selfish
[ __ ] myself included
at least what we left for you was
research on what are the good drugs and
what are the bad drugs
you know because everybody's having all
these [ __ ] breakthroughs with their
mushrooms and [ __ ] i kind of did the
same thing so
you know and then you know then there's
the evil [ __ ]
the coke the heroine synthetic heroin
all of that [ __ ]
we know this stuff bill um anyway this
guy comes up he's he's in the dark room
whatever the [ __ ] he took this guy was
in the dark room so i went up
i did a set uh at supernova i had a
great time
uh just [ __ ] with people i'm really
trying to get my act
where i want it to be because as always
i got [ __ ] to say about the ladies but i
wanna do it
in a way that they're gonna be receptive
okay i don't want them to be like
hey because what's the point of that
they're not going to listen
i want to do it more like a [ __ ]
half-time speech
of how they can get their [ __ ] together
all right and how arrogant is that
for a man to tell women how to get their
[ __ ] together
what kind of a man would do that how
arrogant would i be to do that
i mean what am i a woman only women do
that
my wife is always telling me how i can
be a better person and she does not give
me a half-time speech
she talks to me like the game's already
over and we lost by 40.
the [ __ ] was that out there
i will not be embarrassed like that one
more [ __ ] time
so i'm telling you right now if what i
saw out there today during that brunch
is what the [ __ ] the rest of this shit's
gonna look up that's the door right over
there and you gotta ask yourself
do i wanna be here
uh those are the speeches i get um
not saying i don't deserve it not saying
i don't deserve it right uh yeah cause i
do
um um plus i respond to that i respond
to negativity don't come at me with your
feelings and tell me that you care i
just i'm not even gonna listen to you
i just feel gross and i'm folding myself
in
up into myself or i want to walk out of
the room do not
come with me come at me with love
okay even though that's probably what
the little orange me
from way back in the 70s always wanted
it's too late
okay the feelings are paved over
all right someday someday when they
[ __ ]
you know they they've run out of [ __ ]
land
to build on okay and they put it to a
vote can we dig up all these dead people
and just drop them in the ocean they
won't let the general public
[ __ ] they'll attach it to a bill
something like
you know should ice cream for children
be illegal
right and then if you vote no
you also get to dig up the dead people
that's how they do it
that's how they do it right so then the
politician can get out of it be like
well what was i supposed to say your kid
couldn't have rocky road
so when they dig me up i don't know
where i'm going with this that
like like a [ __ ] archaeological
logical fight
did they be oh look at this [ __ ] guy
he still looks pissed and he's dead he's
supposed to be at peace
oh he died with childhood
he was paved over scientists are
discovering that some of the bodies they
throw into the ocean have a look and
they've decided to keep the bodies above
ground
and examine them they throw all the
happy people in the ocean
um actually speaking of the ocean i'm
gonna get to this drugged up dude in a
minute
speaking of the ocean i heard someone
who's uh
terrified i'm still terrified even
though there was no sharks in the ocean
all right now who have every right to be
there
okay hey i i i you know i'm not racist
against shark sharks i'm just
proud to be a land dweller that's that's
all this rally is about
um shark
uh what the [ __ ] do they call it uh uh
they got this thing now that when you go
into the ocean
you wear it on your ankle if you want to
look sexy or you can have it around your
wrist
um if you're happy in your relationship
or you're not single
and it emits like this [ __ ] uh tone
that they don't like
uh let me i'm just sharp shark tone
safe swimming i think if you wear this
thing
swimming with bull shark now that's
stupid no
did you see that [ __ ] kid from
jackass
covered himself in chum and jumped into
the water with a bunch of [ __ ] sharks
and almost got his goddamn hand bit off
somebody was saying that they have this
[ __ ] shark repellents effective at
protecting swimmers
you'll be hilarious if this finally gets
me to the beach and then i die a
sunstroke
that was like somebody i heard in a
helicopter he had a fully articulated
main rotor system right which means you
can slam the stick forward
and you won't have mass bumping like on
a two bladed system if you were to do
that
you could do it's called a low g push
over you could you know and then your
counter-intuitive move to recover is
half cyclic not to the left or to the
right and you'll chop your tail off mass
pub your main rotor pops off so this guy
was trying to show
that he could do that in his helicopter
and he slammed it forward and he ended
up
he was in such an his attitude was so
severe he
starved the engine of fuel the engine
[ __ ] engine quit and he had to go
into an auto and he [ __ ] up his
helicopter i'm laughing because he lift
uh that would be i'm gonna do the beach
version of that
i got my little bracelet i can go
swimming and you know i don't put any
[ __ ] on my head
i [ __ ] go home looking like hellboy
if you stop working out
um all right the sight of a shark
circling beneath a swimmer's feet as
they enjoy a dip in the ocean is enough
to send any unsuspecting beachgoer into
a state of panic
i don't think that's a state of panic
yeah a state of [ __ ]
obvious emotion
panic is when you're just like i don't
i just don't know what's going to happen
next month will you [ __ ] relax
it's going to be fine you [ __ ] say
this every month you're still here
it's the point everybody that loves you
wants you to die okay
well i'm sorry somebody had to say it
um but you know if you see a shark
swimming underneath an unsuspecting
beach car if it's a suspecting beachgoer
like one of those jackass guys those
lunatics which i'm absolutely gonna
watch that [ __ ] movie
um like talk about the greatest hype
ever for a [ __ ] movie
he did a stunt you're gonna actually get
to watch somebody attacked by a [ __ ]
shark
you know we us everybody went to go see
jaws
to like jaws nine and they all sucked
and that was just
you know [ __ ] fake people getting
eaten real people getting eaten by a
fake shark
there's no [ __ ] way you're not gonna
go see a real person
get bit on the hand that's better that's
better
because it's real um
anyway so i don't think you're you know
if it's a suspecting beachgoer you don't
give me if they're an unsuspecting
beachgoer
you're not in panic you're you're
tapping into
fight or flight so i don't think you're
in a state of panic when you're just
like larry
get the [ __ ] out of the water
dude can we talk about the panic listen
okay i know that there was a shark
underneath his feet and he was
unsuspecting but there was no reason
to bring your voice to that level okay
it was toxic it didn't feel like a safe
environment
i didn't want to fly a kite anymore
anyway however the odds of getting
attacked
and killed by a shark are one in three
point
seven three three hundred wait
three oh jesus 370 wait
three million seven hundred forty that's
why that's why i became a community
three million seven hundred forty eight
you know what it is is they have a comma
after the next
last number instead of a [ __ ] period
and two zeros
three million seven hundred forty eight
thousand
sixty seven
yeah but that's because there's seven
billion people on the planet yeah you're
out of your [ __ ] we're fishing
there's no fish left in the ocean okay
at this point
all right i think you used to just get
those curiosity bites
like what the [ __ ] is that i'm [ __ ]
starving
be like if you went to a [ __ ] foreign
land and you were uncomfortable with
this cuisine he didn't know what
anything was
went to one of those countries where
they have like a [ __ ] yak face
smoked and hanging in the window like i
ain't eating that [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
is that a hoof what is that right and
all of a sudden you know
you're there for a couple days it's just
like
i mean i got to eat i think that's where
sharks are right now
sharks are like barry bonds in like 1998
okay when all of a sudden [ __ ] the
president is calling mark maguire
and sammy sosa and they're not calling
him so he said all right [ __ ] it here's
me on roights
sharks in the same thing like you're
eating all our fish what the [ __ ] are we
supposed to do
you're gonna come in here with your dad
bod all [ __ ] marbled like a [ __ ]
cowboy steak what am i supposed to do
so anyway somebody said there are more
deaths every year from
vending machines and coconuts
said april boyle
april spelled a-p-r-y-l so you know
she's difficult
founder and ceo of el porto shark
an organization that analyzes and
forecasts shark
population data there are an average of
10 shark attacks
every year globally that's pretty insane
my fear is pretty ridiculous
so you know what when you get attacked
by a shark rather than screaming in pain
i think your first
thought you should just
is instead if you have that information
for lifeguards out there
if people are listening to this podcast
maybe when they get bit they don't
have that high-pitched scream anymore
they're just way out in the water and
they just you just hear somebody go
really
[Music]
sharks have killed approximately 50
people in the last century
while humans kill 11 000 sharks every
hour
well i'll tell you these sharks got to
get a [ __ ] pr person huh
they're still the bad guy we're
literally going where they are
despite the low risk if you're a true
environmentalist you got to be rooting
for the sharks right
or does it depend what the person's
wearing that they eat because then those
flippers
if they're made out of some sort of
non-natural
based material that's going to be in the
ocean
uh the big question is are these devices
actually effective
and this is what i love about man's
desire
for [ __ ] women is some douche is
gonna actually go
test it out
you know because i know they're gonna do
it on a dummy first but at some point
it's got to be the real deal
the real heart rate you know because i
guess your heart rate sounds like a
panic seal
this is all [ __ ] i've heard in a bar so
i don't know if any of this is real
um some douche is going to go in
and do it so then he can talk loudly
about if he lives
loudly a bar about it later on in a bar
you know what i mean you got to ask
yourself if you knew how to talk to
women or whatever the [ __ ] you're into
okay whatever pronoun turns you on
if you really knew how to approach this
person would you be [ __ ] doing that
if there's a [ __ ] god that gives a
[ __ ]
which i don't think there is i'm
actually coming back that there is a
higher power and this is just all a
[ __ ] game
okay this eats this this eats that and
then i'll put these people at the top
and they'll [ __ ] have egos
and i'll make sociopaths and narcissists
and uh
and and they'll create money and they'll
oppress each other and i'm just gonna
sit back
and just [ __ ] watch it until it burns
itself down that's what i think it is
so maybe you know god doesn't give a
[ __ ] when you show up
you know hey jesus get in here you gotta
hear this one
start over start over what happened
i thought you're god man i thought you
know everything come on come on just
come on it's my son it's my son he had a
rough one down there just just
tell him the story all right well you
know i was uh
you know i was testing out no no go all
the way back go all the way back
further back let's start in junior high
okay well you know that was around the
time when uh you know
people started getting girlfriends and
boyfriends but it was just sort of the
popular kids so you know it didn't
really bug me but then you know high
school came around and uh
you know it's still kind of the same
boat and uh then i thought i'd all work
out in college and
uh didn't then you know i was like
pushing 30 i was still a virgin and uh
i don't know i just thought i needed
something to talk about tell him what
you did
well uh you know jesus i know you spent
most of your life on land i believe
even when you're on water you're walking
on it so you know i uh
they got these things called sharks is
he listening
all right they got these things called
sharks and uh you know so
they eat people they don't want to so i
put on a device that they said would
work and i
uh you know they chum the water and i
fight jumped it
hey if you guys are laughing at me does
that mean i get in because i'll keep
telling the story
nothing you can do to me will be worse
than what the [ __ ] happened to me down
there man
um anyway several have been tested
and shown some success with certain
sharks
oh jesus but i'm not aware of any
this is what one of the scientists is
saying dr nick
whitney but i'm not aware of any that
have shown to be consistently effective
with multiple species in multiple
situations multiple situations geez
there's a lot in that that little
statement
multiple situations i don't know
bleeding profusely as opposed to
paddling on a wakeboard
there's a lot of situations falling
overboard
on a cruise ship oh my god the ultimate
nightmare
you're just way out in the middle of
nowhere
and there's just nothing there's nothing
out there there's nothing to eat
this is when you're on when you're
[ __ ] driving
you know the 70 or the 80 east or west
when you're going through nebraska
or kansas and you're just like next stop
28 [ __ ] miles
it's like whatever they got to eat it's
a [ __ ] slim jim
or or or some goddamn [ __ ] mom and
pop place you're gonna stop
you might discover a species that never
ate
oh my god oh jesus if i ever go on
another cruise ship
ever i'm gonna have a [ __ ] cyanide
pill
cyanide [ __ ] pill
oh you'd be the worst if you fell
overboard and it fell out of your pocket
where is it
i just started drinking seawater until i
went crazy
uh [ __ ] all right let's get off this
subject
anyway that was excited i thought it
worked let's get back to the drugged up
guy who approached me after the show
shall we people
let's get back to the drugged up guy um
so i did the supernova show
great [ __ ] show great people people
who run the show they know what the [ __ ]
they're doing
uh it's just it's awesome right
so i go down there i do the show
i went on last after the great jeff ross
so i [ __ ] run out of there because
the crowd's coming out
and where i parked my car was right
where the crowd was coming out so i
couldn't like run over anybody
because you know i know what the
headline's gonna be the next day it's
gonna have the comedy and tragedy
[ __ ] picture
first he makes you laugh then he runs
you over
um so i'm sitting in my car
nobody can see me it's night time but
this guy's on coke so they have like
[ __ ] terminator vision
i use that akana he [ __ ] comes up to
my goddamn car
he's okay belt hey bell
i'm ignoring him so i'm like well if i
just let him
keep yelling people are gonna see me and
then i'm gonna track more of this
because all
nice people are just going to be like
well i don't want to bug them that's
what makes them nice
right so i just go i go what
he goes hey man and he had like a
[ __ ] i don't know if it's a hawaiian
shirt and it was some crazy patterned
shirt cargo shorts
he's on his cell phone and he's sweating
so i'm like this isn't gonna be good i
go what and he goes
he goes hey i'm on fox like five times a
week
he goes you want to buy gold you're
interested in buying gold
it's in a parking lot i just go no
he's like all right man all right he
just walks away and i put the [ __ ]
window
up and i'm like why was he sweating so
much i'm like putting it together
you mean somebody come up to you sweaty
saying i sell gold it's like dude you
look like you stole it
you sell it what in a parking lot
did you rob some [ __ ] old people
after you killed them what did we do
what are we doing here
so finally there's a break in the crowd
and i inch my way up
not because i'm courteous i don't want
to get sued so i inched my way out
and i'm [ __ ] driving out of the
parking lot and of course
you know the thing about crazy people is
there's always a sequel
you never just you're never rid of them
they're coming back again
right so i'm pulling out of the parking
lot and there he is
pacing back and forth right on the exit
on his [ __ ] phone
and what's hilarious is a person trying
to drive into the parking lot and he
walks
perpendicular right in front of their
car never looks at him as he's on the
phone
and just holds his hand out like he's a
[ __ ] traffic cop
telling him to stop
so he's on his phone so for half a
second i have hope that he's not gonna
see me again i'm like but he's gonna
because he's crazy
and he's [ __ ] coked up he's got the
terminator vision
so of course as i'm pulling out he's
then [ __ ]
he sees me i just yeah i just bill hey
bell
he goes i just made a half a million
dollars he said something like that just
made a half a million
bill and i just look over and i just go
shut up
[Music]
i drove away
and because i let go of a lot of anger i
was only annoyed
till about halfway down the block which
is really great progress for me
i just started laughing just going like
am i really going to let this guy ruin
my night
i'm on my way over to the comedy store
my favorite place to perform in the
[ __ ] world
and i you know i'm driving and i just
drove over there and i just fight and
i just kind of let the whole [ __ ]
thing go but you know you guys listen
every week i gotta share this story with
you
uh just made a half a million dollars
how [ __ ] hilarious is that
um shout out to fox news
because i trash cnn all of a sudden they
carry it i don't even listen to it they
left out the part
where i [ __ ] said that you know
both cnn and fox news should be broken
up and they should go back to rules
of media ownership so americans will
stop screaming at each other and we can
actually [ __ ] hang out
so you don't have to do blow and try to
sell coke in a parking lot of a [ __ ]
comedy show
um anyway uh
i've been having a great time doing
spots all over the city i'm
just having a [ __ ] great time i'm
getting along with my wife
better than i have in a long time
because i [ __ ] worked on myself
and um which you know is is a [ __ ]
huge thing
we were like hanging out today we're
[ __ ] laughing
just like the old days you know even
though we used to fight back then it was
just it was
a lot easier things are more relaxed
when this you don't have a piece of
paper
legally that says you know
somebody takes half your [ __ ] or
whatever you just fee or you just you
made a person with the other person
there's a lot of extra stress you're
just like [ __ ] i am in this now remember
that great louis ck bit
you know [ __ ] i could have left you know
not that i think that i love my wife to
death but
um anyways we've been getting along
great i've been crushing it
at the gym and more importantly at the
[ __ ]
breakfast table the lunch table the
dinner table and the snack table there's
a lot of tables during the day
all right for those who hadn't been
listening listening for the past couple
weeks oh billy went off the [ __ ]
rails
in june all right there's three family
birthdays this father's day and i ate
at least one and three-quarter triple
layered chocolate cakes myself and i was
up to a buck 90.
it said 189 points something but i
weighed myself after the gym so i was
like 190 190
i don't know what the [ __ ] it was i
don't want to know what i was but
uh i've just been just doing what i need
to do
proteins veggie water
i had one root beer first root beer i've
had all month
don't eat after six workout and cardio
lifting weights cardio cardio burns fat
no yes it does i am down to 181.2
as of today i'm dropping like three
pounds of [ __ ] week
crushing it crushing it
and uh so next week i'm shooting for
178.
following week 175 then i'll be back
down to 172 and i'll be in shape again
that's how it is that's how it works
okay and then i go back to boston and
what sucks is i'll probably put eight
pounds on in a [ __ ] week
because if you think i'm going back
there and i'm not hitting my old all my
old food spots
like i uh like i used to you're out of
your [ __ ] mind i'm going back there
i'm getting the bar pizza i love i'm
getting that
[ __ ] amazing chinese food
what else am i getting there's a couple
of sandwich places i'm hitting the
[ __ ] north end
i'm i'm i'm gonna do some damage all
right
it probably put me two weeks behind but
the bottom line is by the end
of uh september i'm gonna be like
where i need to be as i'm torn so my my
button down my fitted button-down shirts
you got to get the fitted button down
okay so when you the button on your
shirt starts looking like it's doing the
iron cross trying to hold both
[ __ ] sides of the shirt together you
know you need you gotta you gotta drop a
few
so um i've been crushing that
you know my shoulder feels good i got my
uh you know it's funny my wife showed me
this picture of me doing
40 48 push-ups on my 47th birthday
and i looked at my form it was [ __ ]
horrible
and i just saw this thing that was shown
where your hands should be
they should be back a little bit not
like to the side
and it said this right here works your
chest in close works your triceps
this right here gets you injured and
that's how i did push-ups my whole
[ __ ] life i was like wow
so i thought it was the pull-ups it was
i think it might have been the push-ups
and just bad form and other things just
lifting like a kid from his 80s was all
about what you benched
you it was always bench day and [ __ ]
buys and tries
and you never really did your back and
even when you did your back you didn't
know how to do it
so your front got way more [ __ ]
stronger than your back
and then your shoulders went forward and
then you bad form on the push-up and
then there you go
so i've been doing the good form i've
been doing the pull-downs and all of
that [ __ ]
like my back the muscle group that i'm
working is actually
burning now so i know i'm doing it right
it's a good burn man and with that i
waited too long to say this how about
those milwaukee bucks down two games to
none
against the mighty phoenix suns
who i got to tell you that devin booker
kid the the level
of just [ __ ] shots that these kids
can hit nowaday
nowadays there's that [ __ ] white kid
on miami
uh there's obviously i'm so bad with the
names i'm [ __ ] old i'm sorry the
[ __ ]
the kid on on golden state how do you
not know his name
nike didn't know his name did they they
lost that [ __ ]
uh steph curry like well now when i go
back and watch larry bird's shots
his greatest shots of his career it's
like devin booker hits one of those
one or two a half
they're [ __ ] unbelievable and i'm so
enjoying
this is the nba that i remembered these
are like teams not these pylon [ __ ]
let's all [ __ ] get on a yacht and
decide we're gonna [ __ ] play together
[ __ ] [ __ ] uh um you know make a
wish championships
this is like feels like the old [ __ ]
days because this series isn't over
i don't think it's [ __ ] over i i
think that you know
i mean the sun's i don't know i don't
know enough about hoop what the [ __ ]
milwaukee
the adjustments that they made but they
won three [ __ ] games in a row
and uh i watched all of game five i'm
all game four
all a game five i missed the first two
games
i've kind of every game i've watched
milwaukee has won um
and uh giannis antetokounmpo
i hope i said it right chris middleton
and holiday
i forget what the line was but it was
just like 35
27 and 24 or something they're spreading
it around
uh middleton with that i was at
middleton with a holiday holiday with
the steal
the alley-oop to giannis and it's just
like i was so psyched
for giannis on game four
when oscar robinson and kareem
abdul-jabbar show up
i mean that's would be like me doing
stand-up if carlin and prior were still
alive and they showed up
so i guess living now that would be like
eddie murphy
and um
who else i would say sam kinnison if he
was still alive
bill hicks if he was still alive um
i don't know i don't know i'm at a loss
but i would just be like i wonder if
he's [ __ ] nervous
and he play he's played unbelievable
in all three of these games and he's
leading them
just like kareem abdul-jabbar did 50
years ago
unbelievable unbelievable series i am a
fan of the nba again
because this is the nba that i remember
um
absolutely loving it so i'm i'm all over
game
six and seven god willing if there is
one because i i want to see more
basketball
and i got to tell you i started watching
[ __ ] soccer you know i watched that
that uh
that tragedy that was the end of that
[ __ ] game
it just makes sense i mean shakespeare
was over in [ __ ] europe that that's
the way you would decide a [ __ ]
championship
and i got to watch a 19 year old kid put
his face in his shirt and start
crying then all these racist morons say
all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
do you realize how [ __ ] cowardly that
is by the way
to say that [ __ ] online and to take it
to that level
you're not a sports fan you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] so depressing to see that [ __ ]
but anyway i started watching soccer and
then the other day i was just like you
know
you know it's just that weird time of
the year
where there's just baseball and i
haven't gotten around to signing up
to the for the package i still love
baseball but i i
watch a soccer game like san antonio
versus somebody else
and this is how [ __ ] up technology is
all of a sudden i watched i watched two
soccer games last week
and now all of a sudden in my instagram
feed i'm getting all these
soccer highlights it's like they're all
talking to each other man
and i'm kinda really into it now
it only took two games i don't know what
happened
i guess what i'm saying is maybe the
rest of the world is right
there's some game on tomorrow or was it
today i don't know when the [ __ ] it's on
it's like mexico versus el salvador for
you know for some champions how do you
not watch that
getting sucked in man all right let's do
some reads here for the week
let's do some [ __ ] reads all right
indochito
uh it may have been a while
i mean i don't follow you the way my
phone follows me uh it may
it may have been a while since the last
time you had an excuse to dress up
but whatever that next chance is make
the absolute most of it the
cheeto indochino offers completely
custom
fitted suits shirts casual wear and more
at surprisingly affordable prices
you know what i'm going to do i'm going
to get in [ __ ] the best shape of my
life and i'm gonna order one of these
suits like conor mcgregor
you know when you always show up with
those [ __ ] badass fitted suits
but i gotta i gotta can't be billy big
[ __ ] pink tits anymore you know
uh it may have been a while since the
last time i already said that indochino
uh offers completely custom fitted suits
shirts casual wear and more at
surprisingly affordable prices
every piece is made to your exact
measurements and you can customize every
detail choose everything about your suit
from the fabric lapel
monogram and statement linings you can
create a suit that fits you
and your style perfectly the best part
is
cheeto suits start at just 399.
with all customized customizations
included
shop for your next best look or book a
virtual style consultation
at indochito.com i'm doing this i'm
getting in
my [ __ ] fight in shape if i knew how
to fight
um i'm getting into my you look like you
know how to fight shape let's be honest
here
right now you can get fifty dollars off
any per purchase of 399
or more by using the code burp b-u-r-r
at checkout that's fifty dollars off all
purchases of three
wayne gretzky 399 or more at
indocino.com i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o
dot com promo code burr oh look who it
is
me undies look at that [ __ ] shark doo
doo
doo doo me undies me undies he thinks
you're a piece of bark
he takes a bite of your ass people start
to scream
and now you're [ __ ] your bracelet
didn't work and you [ __ ] your pants but
it's nice and [ __ ] soft like me
undies on your ball bag
he thinks you're a piece of bark i don't
know a piece of wood what rhymes a shark
he thinks you're a seal cause it's dark
ah i wish i had that one back me undies
what's something you wear that you can't
see but it can make or break your day
if you guessed underwear then you
probably have
how about a colostomy back
i'm sorry if you guessed underwear then
you probably have a lot of good days
uh seriously there's a reason your
underwear is the first thing you put
on me undies believes you should be
comfortable at your core
that's why they make the softest undies
in fun prints
just let your both have a good day or
your vagine
so you can wake up shout out to borat so
you can wake up
every morning excited to put on your
favorite pair
say bun voyage to the undies you used to
know because comfort starts with
meundies
my undies are designed to be the softest
thing you've ever worn i mean their
signature micro modal
modal fabric literally grows from trees
sustainably sourced undies
they offer different cuts for different
butts ranging from sizes
extra small to four xl so whether you're
looking for classic colors or
adventurous prints
me undies has you covered meundies has a
great offer for my listeners
for any first time purchasers you get 15
off and free shipping
myani's also has their problem free if
you're not satisfied with any product
for any reason
they'll refund or exchange it no caveats
no questions
to get 15 off your first order
you giving me free shipping and 100
satisfaction guaranteed
go to meundies.com that's meundies.com
for 15
off your first order and free shipping
lastly but not leastly oh look who it is
everybody it's stamps.com old reliable
putting money in freckles pockets for
the better part of a decade you know why
because i believe in this goddamn
product
this summer is showing uh this summer is
showing welcoming signs
of a more normal life ahead finally you
can get back to enjoying life's little
pr
pleasures uh like smiling at your
neighbor
you know they could have come up with a
better example than that smiling at your
neighbor
well so they think you're [ __ ] crazy
sorry seeing a movie
and going to the post office okay some
parts of normal life aren't so great but
with stamps.com i just crushed that
punchline by the way
the way i did the little sitcom reversal
i'm really proud of myself
but with stamps.com you can skip trips
uh to the post office and save on
postage with discounted rates
from the united states postal service
and ups
stamps.com saves businesses thousands of
hours and tons of money every year
uh you've heard me talk about stamps.com
they've been sponsoring the show for
over nine years now
and you've and you haven't tried and if
you haven't tried it well what the [ __ ]
are you waiting for
they make it easy for small businesses
to mail and ship without needing to take
a trip to the post office
once your mail is ready just schedule a
pickup or drop it off it's that simple
stamps.com is a no-brainer saving nearly
one
million small business owners like you
time and money
they offer deals you can't get anywhere
else like up to 40
off united states postal service and up
to 66
off usps no you ups
shipping rates and with this switch and
save feature jesus christ
you can quickly compare carriers to find
the best rates every time there's no
risk
and with my promo code bur capital b u r
r
you get a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus freeze both postage
and a digital
scale no long long-term commitments or
contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in bur
that stamps.com promo code burr
okay and with that this is a podcast
for the most part with no guests it
can't be all about me
i want to hear what you guys have to say
okay cigar
bar dreams hey bill
chunky but funky burr ah jesus i love
the fat shaming keep it coming
keep it coming uh i'm writing over in
england and her
heard on your previous podcast your
dream to own a cigar bar
i have this dream and think england
doesn't have many low-key cigar bars
other than the super posh places in
london
question is what makes a good cigar bar
and what would you call yours well i'm
not going to give up the name
if i ever do i will name a bourbon
cocktail served in a large glass
called the oversized ginger
in your honor and you spelt honor rung
you dumb [ __ ]
thanks for being you and go [ __ ]
yourself cheers um
i call him a dumb [ __ ] i can't even
read a number earlier in the podcast
uh what makes a good cigar bar
well obviously the selection
the location it's got to be easy to park
the selection of cigars has to be
[ __ ] top-notch
um also if there's a chance to get
i don't know booze booze becomes a whole
other i wouldn't say booze
because then you get drunks there i
never really noticed that you go to
cigar everybody's just sort of chilling
it's got to have a chill vibe you got to
have nice comfortable seats
your staff has to be like knowledgeable
of the cigars
and they got to be cleaning out the
ashtrays
uh quickly all right um
you gotta have some sort of [ __ ]
those cigar bar games that they have
what i don't i never played them once
some of you roll the dice and you're
moving those checkers
maybe some games like that
um and then a nice fridge
where you sell some soda pop like i like
you know the real [ __ ] the fanta with
the mexican fan and the mexican coke
that has the real [ __ ] sugar in it
and uh root beer bottled waters
something there for the ladies just a
nice chill you know
you got the game on you got to have the
flat screens i'm not going to tell you
anything you don't know
indoor outdoor uh options
um and then the location map is a good
place to get some you know you strike up
a good
uh relationship with the people next
door people can order food and actually
bring it in
there's a whole bunch of ways to go i
mean i don't know
and don't play it loud don't be make it
loud and sexy because then
douches are going to show up um
and it's just going to have you know
that w hotel vibe
you know that with a [ __ ] beautiful
people
you know with the aquarium lighting
don't have that have it be like a nice
chill [ __ ] place um
that's it i really think so much of it
beyond the cigar selection
is the vibe and if you go in there you
got a nice smoke eater so everybody can
smoke inside you're not [ __ ] sitting
there you know
like you're fighting a fire um
you know then who knows maybe you got
some other options in the back if you
know what i mean
that maybe come from a particular place
oh cuban cigar is illegal where you're
at right
so you could have those right out in
front um
i would say that i would say that
that would be it and it was kind of
basic i didn't really have anything
interesting to say did i
yeah because i don't want to give you my
ideas i got a whole [ __ ] bunch of
ideas for it
um but that's the basics i would say and
it seems if you live out in the middle
of no yeah i wouldn't want to make it
posh as you say
the w hotel type of vibe so you got to
be like you know wearing cufflinks and
be super rich
you know and that just really attracts
[ __ ] guys and loud
douchey women who have never been told
to shut their yaps
you don't want that you know
you want those leifer cigar bar guys to
be coming in
um all right cable news dear billy
network
who'd have thought i'd get so much
[ __ ] attention over one stupid
comment
i'm a huge fan of yours and i've seen
you live at least a half a dozen times
in the last 15 years well thank you
appreciate that are you talking about
cable news and how evil it is all the
time
i have worked at two of the major three
cable net
news networks uh oh we got an insider
here
and i just want to tell you that you are
correct yes
how often do you hear that you are
correct sir i entered the news industry
as a naive journalist who thought
news was news but soon came to realize
that it's all selective
coverage yeah that's why when you talk
to people who listen to fox news and
people listen to cnn it's like they're
living in two different countries
uh really interesting stories with
dynamics and huge world implication
hey look who's here
did you bring my baby boy out here to
say goodnight too
wow he's making his first appearance on
the podcast
huh it's because he's jacked how are you
buddy
how you doing you're just looking around
i don't think so that's why he's looking
around say hello to the people
there you go he thinks
can you say ball ball
can you say ball are you getting all shy
like the frog
on the uh bugs bunny show all right i
love you buddy
i'll see you in the morning okay say bye
bye
bye bye you say bye bye you say bye bye
no this is too all too many new
interesting things to look at in here
bye bye you say bye bye
huh he'll do it i know he will
all right what a cutie
all right sweetie i'll see you in a
minute all right i'm wrapping i mean i'm
on the second half here
um anyway i say agenda without
let me go back to you so i get really
interesting stories with dynamics and
huge world implications couldn't be
further from their agenda
i say agenda without exaggeration
yeah i mean it's basically the vision of
the of the
the guy that owns the news network you
know which media has always been that
way that's why you need
rules limiting the ownership and the
influence
um i mean you had half the country
thinking that covid wasn't real the
other half saying it was real i mean
and nobody could get on the same [ __ ]
p we're still not on the same page
because of these two [ __ ] um that own
these networks i think
i'm probably oversimplifying it i know
there's other problems but
um all right here we go it's very clear
what the goal is every day it's not
about letting the public know what's
going on it's about publishing the
public
uh to back one or of two sides
you can imagine how frustrating is
reading the news
but imagine being on the inside and
seeing how hopeless it is yeah that
sounds depressing
needless to say i left the world and
started my own business a year ago
thanks for the free podcast go [ __ ]
yourselves now i want to ask the people
that actually watch cnn and fox news
all right did this mean anything to you
i mean this person could have made that
up who knows if they worked there or not
but
does it give you a pause
i'll tell you i was at the gym and they
had cnn on and like i had almost a panic
attack
within [ __ ] five minutes of looking
at it i'm like dude i can't i come here
to
like feel good you know
they just scream in fire in a crowded
movie theater every [ __ ] two seconds
anyway naming names yo billy bond
uh you've had a don't name names policy
for a while now
you leave names out of stories all the
time i was wondering
if you were to name the people you
complain about
how much would that affect your career i
have to believe not so much
aside from a few less invites to a
shitty panel show
that you're already not doing thanks and
[ __ ] off yourself
uh no just in general a lot of times
when i tell stories like you know
something crazy happened and i feel like
you know you need consent so i
change where it happened
and you know what you know not what
happened but where it happened or
whatever but um
why is my [ __ ]
my [ __ ] computer scream is blinking
like an old tv all of a sudden not jesus
it's just because i'm trashing [ __ ]
social uh not social media
major uh news channels uh yeah i just
don't i don't do that [ __ ]
listen i know that you guys are now
you guys are like the [ __ ] rat
generation everybody's just trying to
rat everybody out and
end their ability to make money and and
all of this
i don't want to [ __ ] do that to
anybody you know what i mean if
somebody's really doing something bad i
feel like the cops are going to show up
there's lawyers there's there's other
ways of doing it there's a whole [ __ ]
real system that exists
outside of social media i would you know
my [ __ ] is like if i get a problem with
somebody
i go to them and i [ __ ] work it out
if it's at another level i'd go to the
cops
but uh i'm not gonna [ __ ] be you know
telling stories of [ __ ] that i've done
with people that you know might make
them look in a certain way
and also when i comment on people saying
[ __ ]
on social media i don't become part of
the problem and say their [ __ ] names
that's i don't understand chiming in
on a [ __ ] story when i wasn't there
and somebody's livelihood is is
at stake i get if you were there
then you tried to go to some authorities
and nobody [ __ ] listened
then i get it but you know if i wasn't
there
why i'm not gonna [ __ ] weigh in on
either side
i think that makes sense doesn't it why
is my screen [ __ ] blinking up jesus
okay england's so-called fans oh boy oh
boy here we go somebody's gonna shoot
one across the bow here
hey billy belly bulge oh you
[ __ ] it's so true
england is a [ __ ] country with [ __ ] fans
all right this sounds like it's [ __ ]
open-minded
how many ways did england fans act like
complete [ __ ]
hooligans it's hard to keep track here's
a few well i did see them when they were
[ __ ]
beating on those poor italian fans just
coming in to watch a game
booing opposing teams national anthem
they did do that laser pointers at the
opposing goalie i didn't know they did
that oh wow
crashing the gate at wembley
yeah what is with that i got to tell you
england this is what happens when your
cops don't have guns
beating up at the italian fans before
and after the game
yeah that's that's so [ __ ] weak
[ __ ] 10 on one the [ __ ] are you doing
tearing apart
fan zones throughout london i don't even
know what that means
smashing bottles destroying property
ripping up trees
it's what did the [ __ ] tree do
breaking into the national gallery i
don't even know what that is
the disgusting racist remarks towards
their own players
congratulations and go italy and england
go [ __ ] yourself
um this little gem of a pick
is what this place is like in a nutshell
yeah it's somebody with a [ __ ]
firework shooting it out of his [ __ ]
uh well i mean i don't think all english
fans are like that and i also don't
think everybody in italy is a saint
same way in america we all have we all
have our issues and then individually
we all have our issues you know some
days you wear the white hat some days
you wear the black hat some days you're
a good person some days you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
as long as you're working on yourself
and you own up to your mistakes you
apologize
i mean i think that's how an adult
behaves i i just don't understand
doing any of that why would you go
destroy your own city why would you boo
an opposing team's national anthem why
would you want to win because you're
doing the laser pointer thing why would
you do that [ __ ]
yeah ah that's because you're a [ __ ]
animal all right
yeah i can't argue with any of that
stuff but i i would be uh
wouldn't you say that most
you know sports uh what would you say uh
fan bases have those types of people
know what i mean as a boston fan i know
we do
we absolutely do it's [ __ ] disgusting
but uh and then of course that's what
they show on the [ __ ] news so i know
you're
going after the morons i don't think
i would be willing to say 90 of soccer
fans in england aren't like that
um it's just a select few
i mean that's a great way to [ __ ]
clear people out of your population
you have your team lose a major
championship on a penalty kick
and then you just wait for that reaction
and you just wipe out all of those
people and everybody who stayed home and
didn't write anything bad
jesus christ bill what are you going
hitler on this here you're going to
decide who you're going to [ __ ]
do you're coming up with your own final
solution for sports i don't know what
i'm doing here
whatever that's what happens when you
talk to yourself too long all right
mexican stereotype
hey billy bob borton
borton oh like i'm boring you you
[ __ ]
uh i'm a 29 year old mexican-american
tax accountant from san diego oh you're
living in god's country
san diego that's like la without the
traffic
it's super chill i love san diego
and your podcast helps me plow through
the endless amount
of excel spreadsheets book to tax
reconciliation and procrastination
procrastinating clients
that wait until the last week of tax
season to provide their documentation
isn't that something then they just
dumped it dirty dishwater in your laugh
you're a saint wreaking havoc to my
mental sanity
time and time again but i digress
so i recently went to a friend's
birthday reunion
uh where she also invited a few people
that i had not had the pleasure of
meeting before
everything was going nice and dandy went
out of the [ __ ] blue
a mildly drunk blonde lady he said dame
or
lady approached the table and sat next
to me
to engage in a a seemingly polite
conversation
oh yeah what could go wrong here you're
in san diego some beautiful blonde's
talking to you
you're being chill you're not bringing
any negative energy towards yourself
what could happen
we discussed what we did for a living
backgrounds and all the base
that basic stuff as we were talking she
began
inching closer little by little reaching
the point where she casually
rested her palm on my leg as we were
sitting talking
as she got closer and closer i sensed
the pungent whiff of tequila and vodka
that they were passing around to then
realize that she was pretty much
hammered when arriving to this
realization i quickly disengaged
and moved over to some other friend's
table well aren't you a gentleman
as the night went forward look at this
you did you did the right thing
you were raised right as the night went
forward one of my friends dropped a bowl
full of chips
and i quickly reached over for a broom
to help clean up the mess
and oh no and out of nowhere the drunk
blonde chick appeared from behind
and aggressively took the broom off of
my hands and then yelled
oh no i will not keep alive the mexican
cleaning guy stereotype let me take care
of it
oh god
oh my god as soon as the words came out
of her mouth everyone in the room went
went silent and i was the only one
laughing i actually thought it was funny
like yeah i can see why as a white
person it's embarrassing the moment she
left the party
i had numerous people approach me and
apologize for her comment
when i truly did not see what was the
big deal up to the point you know
it's white guilt it's white guilt
because all of them probably had
mexican people doing something over
their house as they act like they're
good parents
um i truly did not see what the big deal
was up to the point
where all of these people made me
question myself if i should have been
offended or not no that's up to you
that's up to you but you gotta
understand the way the world is now
we're all just like ah not the woke
douche
and you're also an accountant and she's
coming over just being like why should
the mexican guy sweep up yeah that's a
lie
i can see why people weren't comfortable
he said i should i believe we should all
be able to dish it and take it at the
same time
people nowadays find a fence uh whenever
being the butt end of a joke
is this one of those situation or
was that not cool to say well if you
thought it was fine then i guess it's
fine but it's like you know it's also
not a level playing field so
you know i don't know no matter i really
feel like as a white person no matter
how you react in that situation you're
going to be wrong like
how could you just let her say that or
then why did you feel the need to
apologize
um looking forward to your take on this
thanks and go fornicate yourself um
i'll be honest with you uh
back in the day when i grew up that is
something that you would say
and everyone would [ __ ] actually
people would say would have said worse
than that
um i'm not saying racial slurs but the
jokes would have been way more [ __ ]
the way the you know the way it used to
be uh
i'd say a nice archie bunker type of
thing
i still love jokes like that but when
you get into a public place and
everybody has
cameras and everybody's just waiting to
film somebody saying something [ __ ] up
uh but no i don't think you're i mean
your reaction is your reaction
so i don't know what to tell you on that
i thought you were going to be like i
thought you were going to get upset
so i think i'm part of those i mean
there's no [ __ ] way i would have gone
up to you and apologized for
i mean i probably yelled something at
her go home you're [ __ ] drunk i would
have said something like that
but uh you know
there's a big pressure night now to be
to to be
a white person and pretend like you care
that's all it is
you know and that's like minimal work
you know those white people could
actually be down at the border
protesting why those children are in
cages
or they could just go up to be like oh
my god my heart breaks for what she just
said to you
i did my good white person thing for the
day then they could walk away
i don't [ __ ] know i don't live in
that world sir
so i i don't i don't know what to
[ __ ] tell you um all i can tell you
is i wish people brought you their tax
[ __ ]
you know you know not on april 13th
or whatever the [ __ ] it is that they do
you know rip the [ __ ] band-aid off
just bring it to them in february and in
march
they'll get it done you're gonna know
what what way you stand
with uncle sam and the bankers that
[ __ ]
make him walk the block like a [ __ ]
old prostitute
um there you go underrated overrated
underrated getting your taxes in
and done and just letting them take
take a bite out of your ass or get your
[ __ ] refund whatever the [ __ ] you
have coming to you
getting that out of the way as opposed
to just waiting
to the last second um
is definitely underrated all right well
that is the podcast everybody
uh i want to thank all you guys for
listening as always
uh as always go [ __ ] yourselves i want
to thank you guys for the fat
shaming i love it i guess this is where
i can bond with this uh
mexican-american guy here where i you
know where some people would find it
offensive
i [ __ ] love it i find it motivating
um so keep the fat shame and coming but
i tell you you only got a couple weeks
left
okay because i looked at my body mass
index
and it said when i get down to 173 i
will just be in shape
you know for some reason at my height
you can be 129 to 173.
i don't know what kind of bird bones you
have or if you're running behind the
dumpster every five [ __ ] seconds
chewing and spitting whatever the [ __ ]
it is you're doing i don't know how you
get down to 129 that might be for like
women you know
certain wafey women
how come you can be 173 the woman can't
i'm not saying that
abigail i'm not saying that i don't give
a [ __ ]
it's your [ __ ] body do whatever
whatever weight you think you look good
at do that
i don't give a [ __ ] it's that's not up
to me to make you feel good go [ __ ]
yourself i'm you'll be yelling at
somebody who isn't even there right now
all right that's it go [ __ ] yourselves
i'll check get on you
on thursday